ses deux voisines ont une âme
d'aventurière et veulent le prouve et
flore faille et véronique dubois deux
habitants de bois d'arcy veulent
participer à l'édition 2010 est du raid
des alizés une compétition 100 %
féminine organisée en martinique
l'idée a été lancée par flore la
sportive a déjà disputé l'épreuve en
2016 l'année dernière j'avais suivi un
peu à ce qu'elle avait fait et puis
cette année elle me l'a proposé et donc
j'y ai réfléchi parce que ça demande
réflexion quand même de s'investir dans
ce type de projet et
et puis je me suis décidé à le faire
puisque voilà j'ai une année transitoire
dans ma vie j'ai 40 ans cette année
et là je me suis dit ma chouette il faut
que je prenne des challenge est donc
voilà je lui ai dit oui pour pouvoir
réaliser les cinq jours d'épreuves et
terminer le plus haut possible les deux
arcisienne s'entraîne plusieurs fois par
semaine
courir forcément est le plus gros du
travail se fait dans le travail du
dénivelé est pour moi le kayak en
martinique a beaucoup de dénivelés on
sait pas dans quelles proportions et on
va en avoir mais c'est sûr il y en aura
je me met progressivement et puis avec
des aides le l'expérience aussi de
fleurs parce qu'elle est très sportive
du coup elle m'apporte beaucoup puisque
la questionne et puis j'ai voilà je
questionne aussi le tournoi tous les
sportifs pour ce qui serait mieux pour
moi pour me préparer pour participer ces
deux têtes brûlées doivent collecter
8500 euros d'ici le 1er septembre pour
le moment cette équipe baptisée mnm smad
elle-même sonara côté que 1500 euros un
défi de plus pour les deux athlètes